like when they're like we don't have it
as good as our parents generation I'm
like no no don't read a headline tell me
about you I don't want to know about gen
Z or Boomers or Millennials or Gen X
tell me about you and all and all sudden
it becomes a game of account
if you decide that you saw two tick
tocks and they say that gen Z doesn't
have it as good as their parents had it
and you just believe that well it's a
wrap if you also realize that there's
unlimited kids on Tick Tock right now
making more money and are happier than
their parents were you're all of a
sudden like saying wait it is possible
so to me what do I tell the kids to stop
talking in generalization and start
talking about themselves and start
focusing on what they're gonna do about
it